[Música]
economía en directo América me acompaña
en el estudio Luis Méndez Luis Buenas
noches vamos a comenzar esta sección en
el Reino Unido porque en ese país la
tasa de inflación registró su valor más
elevado en los últimos 40 años así es
Santiago en ese país los precios
registraron un alza de un punto
porcentual en 12 meses hasta el pasado
mes de octubre del presente año hasta
alcanzar el
11,1% desde un 10,1% que fue registrado
en el mes de septiembre el dato se
presenta un día antes de que el actual
Primer Ministro Richi snack ofrezca
detalles de sus medidas presupuestarias
pero conozcamos en el siguiente informe
los factores que afronta Reino Unido y
que han provocado el alza en los precios
el banco de Inglaterra pronosticó a
principios de este mes que la inflación
del Reino Unido alcanzaría un máximo de
alrededor del 11% en el cuarto trimestre
la tasa de inflación interanual de
octubre está un poco por encima de esa
cifra en el 11,1 el nuevo Primer
Ministro británico rishizunak en su
intervención en el g20 de Bali en
Indonesia culpó de las tensiones
económicas directamente a la guerra de
Vladimir Putin en Ucrania
deberíamos ser claros nada de esto
estaría ocurriendo si no fuera por la
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania Esta es la
cruel e implacable realidad de la guerra
de Putin y mientras continúen seguirá
devastando la economía mundial
los precios de los alimentos en el Reino
Unido subieron varios puntos por encima
de la tasa de inflación General ya que
los supermercados trasladaron el aumento
de Los costos a los consumidores el
precio de la electricidad y el gas
natural también fue significativamente
superior al Reino Unido le va peor que a
la mayoría de los países en lo que es
una tendencia mundial la directora
general de la Organización Mundial del
Comercio en declaraciones a France 24
durante la Cumbre del g20 en Bali afirmó
que la guerra en Ucrania ha exacerbado
una serie de factores que alimentan la
inflación
tuvimos la pandemia tuvimos el estímulo
fiscal tuvimos mucha demanda en el
sistema creo que es más productivo
intentar averiguar Cómo frenar esta
inflación que entrar en un juego de
culpas
mientras el Reino Unido espera las
medidas presupuestarias clave el jueves
otros países observarán como sus tasas
de inflación continúan al alza entramos
ahora en información empresarial porque
el nuevo dueño de Twitter y long musk
retrasó hasta finales de este mes de el
nuevo servicio que tenía previsto para
la compañía así es Santiago se trata de
la marca de verificación que hasta la
compra por parte de Mods distinguía a
celebridades y personalidades del mundo
de la política y que llevó al nuevo
dueño a implementar a una suscripción
que tendrá que pagar de acuerdo con su
nuevo dueño la modificación fue
considerada un retraso menor en el
cronograma para asegurarse de que sea
sólido como una roca se espera que entre
en vigencia el 29 del presente mes de
noviembre y está orientado para hacer
que la empresa gane dinero con esta
suscripción por otro lado también el ceo
de la empresa tesla volvió a lanzar
presión sobre los trabajadores de
Twitter expresando que o trabajan duro
Se comprometen con un delicado trabajo o
abandonan la empresa Pero toda esta
situación se está presentando en medio
de un juicio que afronta y lo mostras
una demanda interpuesta en su contra por
el pago de 56 mil millones de dólares
por parte de tesla a Moss como una
remuneración
ahora de temas de América Latina Luis en
Venezuela allí hay un acuerdo con
diferentes Voceros oficiales y siguen
consolidando el retorno de la
conectividad aérea Tal parece que las
aerolíneas se interesan por volver al
mercado venezolano y esto de acuerdo con
algunos organismos internacionales que
el país está dando claros avances hacia
una mejora económica pero esto lo acaba
de anunciar el presidente del Instituto
Nacional de aeronáutica civil Juan
Manuel teixeira durante una entrevista
concedida a la radio venezolana Unión
radio aunque no específico detalles
aseguró que al menos 12 aerolíneas
internacionales estarían negociando
incorporar a Venezuela dentro de su
conectividad aérea también se refirió a
la visita de la asociación internacional
de transporte aéreo iata e Indicó que el
organismo actuó como mediador para
diversas reuniones con organizaciones
nacionales vinculadas al sector aéreo y
entes gubernamentales tenemos una
ubicación geográfica envidiable nuestro
combustible es hoy en día el más barato
del mundo ofrecemos ventajas en todos
nuestros aeropuertos que son de primera
línea por estar ubicados en posiciones
al nivel del mar Este es el interés y
nosotros mediamos en esto apuntó en un
fragmento de la conversación también se
refirió a la conectividad aérea entre
Colombia y Venezuela que se retomó el
pasado mes de septiembre esta llegó tras
varios años de estancamiento por el
momento son dos aerolíneas las que están
volando entre Caracas y Bogotá poco a
poco se Irán anunciando Cuáles se
sumarán a esta conexión fue otra de las
frases de el presidente del inac en
Venezuela La pregunta es qué garantías
tienen para repatriar sus ganancias
estas aerolíneas razón por la que se
fueron de ayer Muchas gracias Luis es
todo por el momento en la economía ya
viene el debate
[Música]